hello everybody and welcome to a new
batch of Pi game tutorial videos in this
video I'm going to show you guys how we
can draw things with PI game a lot of
other things because so far we've just
done rectangles but you can draw a lot
of things with PI game if you've seen my
other series for pi game back in Python
2.7
so it'd be very similar to a video we
did there and then after this I'm going
to show you guys how to make buttons as
well as like an intro screen to our game
because these are kind of necessary
things and strangely enough PI game does
not have a buttons functionality built
in so I definitely felt like those
should be covered so anyway with that
let's go ahead and get started here what
we're going to go ahead and do you need
to keep the original script here so I
would save that somewhere and then what
I'm going to go ahead and do is just
like ctrl a delete so I'm just going to
clear the slate here so like I said
we're going to be going back to our game
that we just wrote so we'll come back to
that so keep that but right now I just
wanted to clean the slate make this as
basic as possible so um we're gonna go
ahead and obviously import PI game and
then we need to do PI game dot in it for
initiating PI game now what do we need
to do well um we're really drawing and
so I think it's a good idea to go ahead
and define a bunch of colors so we can
actually draw things so we can define
white really easily why it is basically
everything maxed out so 255 255 255
black is basically nothing so 0 0 0 and
then we can define red green and blue
very simply right out of the gate so red
would be to 255 0 0 green would is to 0
255 0 and then blue is 0 0 255 so now
we've got white black red green blue and
that should be enough colors for us to
get a pretty good distance here
so now let's define a display real quick
so we're gonna say game
display and that's going to equal pi
game dot display dot set underscore mode
in here um we'll just do another 800 by
600 that's fine
then um that's it that's all we really
have to do as you guys should remember
from back in the day um we can fill the
game display by doing a game display dot
bill and let's give it a white
background again like we did before
actually it's give it a black background
because some of this stuff will be hard
to see so we'll do fill with a black
background and then what we can ask is
um we just write a quick while true loop
and this will be our game loop so to
speak something to make some space here
so while true what do we actually want
to do here and we're just going to say
for event in pi game dot event diet get
we just need a way to really quit here
we're just gonna say if the vent dot
type equals pi game dot quit what do we
want to do well we want to do pi game
dot quit and quit and that should cover
cover that and then we'll just run a PI
game dot display dot update here and
that will update our display and that's
basically all we need let me make this
white just to make sure everything
worked let me run that really quick good
we got no errors and that that ran so
I'm close out of this cocoa pool so now
I'm ready to show you guys like all the
things that we can do for drawing so the
first thing I want to cover is just a
straight pixel so we can actually draw
pixel by pixel on Pi game in the way
that we do this is we can call the
entire game display and we can convert
the game display into what's called a
pixel array and it's going to be an
array of pixels and the pit each pixel
will be a I hate to say list because I
yeah it's going to be a list because we
can modify them you can't
Bible so it's like a list and it's a
two-element list and you've got the
first element or 0with element is going
to be the x value of that pixel and then
the first element or the second part
will be the Y element so we can
reference specific pixels this way and
then we can redefine those pixels as
well so not only can we get the color of
those pixels if we need to for whatever
reason the real thing that we can do is
actually redefine those pixels so let us
do this
so we could say um pix array equals PI
game dot pixel array and then what do we
want this pixel array of we're going to
do game display which is the entire
display so we can actually reference
this to any any surface object which
just so happens that we're using one
major surface object right now so game
display so that's a pixel array so
that's 800 by 600 so that that's the
array that we're working with so now we
can reference something within it and
I'm going to change this fill now to
black so we can see what we do here in a
moment and what we can say now is we can
say underneath this pixel array we could
say pix array and then we'll reference
what do we want to reference what we
want to reference values in that array
and we'll say we want to reference X&Y
so we could say like if X is 10 and Y is
20 so pixel X of a 10 and Y of 20
basically what is that value well we can
say whatever we want it to be so we
could make that color let's make it
green okay so now we can save and run
that and it's probably very hard to see
on my screen but on yours if you've been
following along you should be able to
see that green pixel right there and
that is how you can redefine redefine
some pixels
so we'll do that um now the next thing
that I want to show you guys is we can
also draw lines so we'll leave that
pixel there and we'll just we'll just
keep drawing stuff to the screen so the
next thing we can do is pygame dot draw
dot line where do we want to draw that
line to the game display what color do
we want that line let's make the line um
we did green let's do well do one two
blue and then the next question is for a
line you've got a start start point and
end point both those are tuples and
they've got width so a start point for
our line could be a 100 200 okay comma
now the next parameter will be another
tuple and the end point will be 300 of
450 and then the thickness of our line
we'll do five pixels thick so nor my
phone so we'll save and run that and
we'll see our line now so now you can
see that we've got this blue line and
again to do that you just specify the
starting point and the end point easy
enough so close out of this and what
else can we draw well we can also draw
obviously you already knew about
rectangles but let's go ahead and draw a
rectangle really quick just to get it
out of the way so pygame dot draw rect
where do we want to draw it game display
what color do we want it let's make it
red and then um a rectangle you specify
the top left X&Y and then you specify
the width and the height and all of this
goes in its own little tuples so for
example our rectangle will start at at
400 400 and then we'll make it 50 pixels
wide and 25 pixels tall and that's it
for our rectangle save and run that one
there she is beautiful beautiful the
next thing that we can do is we can draw
a circle
and to do that it is pygame dot draw dot
circle and a circle you specify the
center of the circle and then you
specify the radius of that circle and
you can also specify the edge width if
you'd like but that just confuses me so
well we're going to go ahead and do is
where do we want to draw it game display
what color we want the circle let's make
it white and then what will be the
center of the circle let's do um one
fifty one fifty and then how how what's
the radius of the circle
we'll choose um let's do 7-5 7-5 run
that and now we've got a circle here
okay so that pretty much covers it
as far as shapes that you can draw the
only additional thing that we can do is
we can draw um any polygon that we can
think of we can draw this one I don't
foresee people using as much but you can
and you can use it to draw anything so
it can be useful and unlike loading
sprites you can use accelerated graphics
very well with drawing objects so it
might be in your best interest to draw
objects by a pie game but anyway it's
kind of neat that you can do it so I'm
going to show you guys anyways so pie
game dot draw dot a polygon polygon as
usual we say where do we want it we're
gonna say game display what color do we
want it let's see we've done red green
let's do green because we only have a
pixel let's bring red our green rather
and then you start and then you have
like this parameter and it's good this
parameter is a tuple and it's gonna be
full of tuples of x and y coordinates
and each tuple is going to be a mark on
that polygon so for example we could do
a twenty five seventy five so that's the
first point of our polygon then we'll do
comma another tuple
76 125 and then comma one more tuple
let's add a 250 I 375 so um let me just
close this off and make sure we don't
okay we have enough parentheses there um
so let's save and run that and see what
we've got
so we have this a really really long
triangle basically okay so we can close
out of that and so that's why you don't
have triangles by the way so those are
three points but we can keep adding
points here so we could now say another
point that we want to have is let's do X
of 400 and a y of 25 let's save and run
that one and now you can see how we've
like stretched out the the original one
so if you recall this this was the last
point so it went like this
down here and then basically back and
now we've actually got four sides even
though this it might be kind of hard to
tell initially but we've got a one two
three four so then you can you could do
something like let me just add a bunch
here
so we've got 400 comma 25 then we could
add um let's do 65 40 let's run that one
now hopefully that will give me an
overlap yes so as you can see it's
almost like we took it and we twisted it
a little bit here it's all the same
polygons of course but it's in the order
of dots that we drew so we could draw
these dots in in a different order and
actually have them all connecting in the
way that we wanted but it's basically
going to connect the dots in the exact
order that you wrote them in so anyways
um that about covers it as far as like
drawing with the PI game drawing
functionality so you can do everything
from straight-up pixel by pixel if you
want or you can draw circles lines
rectangles obviously and then just like
any polygon you can pause
think of so um just keep those in mind
as far as things that you can do and I
did just want to cover that at least
again for pi PI game in Python 3 so
hopefully you guys are all caught up if
you do have any questions or comments
feel free to leave them below as always
thanks for watching things for all the
support and subscriptions and until next
time